bonsoir bonsoir qu'est-ce qui vous fait
douter pourquoi vous êtes prêts de dire
maintenant que c'est à peu près sûr je
suis capable de vous dire maintenant que
c'est à peu près sûr mais je préfère
qu'on ait des données encore de quelques
jours pour confirmer le tout au
gouvernement et faire en sorte de lui
suggérer de retirer le port du masque
obligatoire pour à peu près le 14 mai
donc samedi le 14 mai où la journée
d'avant mais ça va être autour de ça OK
et là vous allez dire quoi exactement
vous allez dire c'est mieux qu'on de
continuer à le porter ou vous pouvez
l'enlever puis il y a pas de problème ce
qu'on va dire c'est ça va dépendre où on
va être rendu le 14 mais quand je dis 14
là c'est ça dépend bien sûr si les
prochaines journées nous invite à
recommander cela et ça dépend si le
gouvernement va prendre notre
recommandation il y a d'habitude de nous
écouter attentivement mais ce que en
gros ce qu'on va dire le 14 c'est
regarder il y a une période maintenant
qui est différente on arrive avec
évidemment une circulation du virus qui
va être moins grande que celle qu'on a
connu récemment mais on invite les gens
à être respectueux pour ceux chez qui il
deviendra encore
utile de porter le masque et là on parle
des gens qui sont plus vulnérables donc
des personnes plus âgées des personnes
qui sont immunos supprimées des
personnes qui font l'infection et qui
choisissent après quelques jours
d'isolement d'aller faire une course ou
l'autre on leur demande de porter le
masque et tant mieux alors il y aura des
situations comme ça c'est pour ça qui
faut déjà s'habituer à ce que il y a une
partie de la population qui continue à
porter le masque il faut pas se
surprendre ça faut pas s'en offenser il
faut respecter ça il faut encourager
aussi le port du masque à nouveau si
jamais le virus reprenait de l'élan on
le recommanderait aux gens mais pour les
transports en commun vous allez quand
même continuer à recommander le port du
masque en fait ça sera obligatoire de
les transports en commun le port du
masque il faut rester obligatoire dans
les transports en commun dans deux
semaines si parce que dans le virus
d'abord il est très présent encore on a
des milliers de cas à chaque joue des
milliers de cas à chaque jour encore de
les donner de ses renouveau dans ce sens
là et les autres indices qu'on a aussi
mais donc après le 14 les gens dans le
transport en commun vont être invités à
maintenir le masque parce que dans le
transport en commun vous faites debout
dans le métro à côté de quelqu'un
d'autre très proche ça dépend de la
densité des gens alors là vous avez pas
trop le contrôle de ce qui se passe on
pense que c'est plus simple c'est plus
correct de le faire ainsi mais si le
virus est très présent comme vous dites
puis on le voit autour de nous puis pour
les entreprises d'un casse-tête parce
que les gens sont pas très malade
nécessairement mais ils sont pas au
bureau pendant 5 au moins cinq jours
s'il est très présent quel est
l'avantage d'enlever le masque
l'avantage dans une masse c'est de
reprendre une vie pour les gens où ils
vont être capables de contrôler leur
propre situation il y a des gens qui ont
fait l'infection récemment qui ne la
refonte pas dans les prochaines journées
les prochaines semaines et qui savent
qu'ils peuvent se promener sans masque
pas de risque pour eux il y a pas de
risque pour les autres et c'est tant
mieux donc des choix qui peuvent se
rendre individuels mais dans une pensée
plus collective c'est à dire on pense
aux autres si on est malade on le porte
si on voit qu'il y a quelqu'un qui est
plus sensible on respecte le fait qu'ils
portent le masque alors faut s'habituer
à ça parce que le virus n'est pas parti
avec la fin de cette vessie il va
continuer alors faut prendre des gestes
tous ensemble qui vont nous permettre de
vivre avec ça individuellement et
collectivement et vous êtes docteur il
faut respecter les gens qui vont vouloir
se protéger garder le masque ça me
paraît évident mais il va falloir aussi
une fois que ce n'est plus obligatoire
respecter les gens qui vont l'enlever
tout à fait il y a des gens qui nous
juste en rentrant ici à Radio-Canada
quelqu'un m'interpelle pourquoi je suis
encore obligé de le porter de
visiblement il voulait l'enlever bientôt
alors ça va venir espérons sous peu mais
cette personne là m'a confié dis-moi
j'ai fait le virus il y a à peine trois
semaines puis je me sens très bien
maintenant mais tant mieux alors ben
c'est à dire sera mieux qu'il est fait
donc il y a toutes sortes de situations
mais faut respecter ceux qui ne voudront
pas le porter il faut respecter ceux qui
voudront le porter et vous savez il y a
des endroits dans le monde où ce
respect-là n'est pas encore parfait et
qui déteint sur différentes postures
politiques c'est pas ce qu'on veut ici
mais justement à l'inverse on se rend
parmi les derniers jours je vous montre
une carte là vous allez voir du Canada
Colombie-Britannique le 11 mars a été
levé
Alberta le premier mars on le sait ils
étaient pressé premier mars ça se
scatchewan 15 mars l'Ontario se fait
quand même plus d'un mois
et tous les promesses maritimes le voyez
on est les derniers pourquoi qu'est-ce
qui est différent au Québec docteur
Boileau qui fait qu'on doit qu'on devait
être plus prudent qu'ailleurs
il y a certainement trois considérant le
premier c'est qu'on a un système de
santé ou un système de soins un système
hospitalier en particulier qui était
plus fragile et on l'a beaucoup entendu
énormément d'efforts qui ont été faits
pour stabiliser ça et il y a des plans
pour le stabiliser qui sont sur la table
et qui vont qui sont très prometteurs
mais une fois cela dit c'est un système
qui ne pouvait pas être mis en ballotage
trop solide par une nouvelle vague trop
forte ça c'est la première des choses la
deuxième excusez-moi on avait un moins
bon système de santé moins robuste donc
on pourrait pas se permettre comme
ailleurs de de tirer l'élastique un peu
plus c'est la première raison la
deuxième raison c'est que nous avons eu
une vague un peu plus forte ici
qu'ailleurs un peu plus tôt donc si vous
regardez sur l'échelle canadiennes cette
vague là nous est venue nous chercher un
peu plus vite et un peu plus solidement
que ce qu'on a vu à des dates
équivalentes mais parce qu'il rentrait
un peu plus ici il y a une contamination
qui s'est passé mais ailleurs en ce
moment ils ont ils sont sur une vague un
peu plus haute que la nôtre en ce moment
ils aimeraient ça
des courbes qui vont par un bas ce qui
n'expérimente pas comme nous on commence
déjà à voir au Québec donc on a
peut-être une semaine d'avance sur eux
ou deux semaines maximum la troisième
raison c'est que nous avons une
population qui est un peu plus fragile
que les autres populations canadiennes
vous l'avez vu dans le recensement
récemment on a des personnes un peu plus
âgées alors comme moyenne alors il y a
des groupes comme ça qui pour lesquels
il faut être un peu plus sensible et je
pense que ça ça explique sa légitimise
le fait qu'on les garder mais l'autre
raison aussi c'est que tous les sondages
qui sont faits nous montrer que la
majorité des gens était confortable avec
cela ils se sentait plus en sécurité
avec cela c'est pas le seul moyen qu'il
fallait prendre pour se protéger mais
c'est une habitude qui s'est bien ancrée
dans celle des citoyens qui je pense
pour plusieurs va persister et c'est une
bonne chose oui mais ça on vous entrez
dans le domaine plus politique qui est
pas censé être le vôtre que les gens
adhèrent à une mesure ne devrait pas
influencer s'il mesure est encouragée ou
pas scientifiquement en fait c'est une
touche scientifique importante c'est à
dire ce qu'on appelle l'acceptabilité
populationnelle d'une mesure c'est
quelque chose d'important ce n'est pas
politique là c'est vraiment une mesure
de santé publique parce que des fois où
il y a des choses qui leur apparaissent
inacceptables faut penser à d'autres
choses mais ici c'est quelque chose qui
était vu comme acceptable en ce moment
mais il faut pas prolonger ça induitment
on peut pas être les seuls non non il y
a des limites deux importantes questions
avant de vous laisser aller les
réinfections d'une part et l'automne
d'autre part les réinfections là on voit
des gens qui sont réinfectés en rythme
assez élevé et ça dire que l'efficacité
des premières 2e 3e dose
décroît très rapidement pourquoi nous
sommes réinfectés comme ça en fait le
vaccin ou les vaccins sont très
efficaces pour prévenir la manifestation
grave de la maladie de prévenir la
contagion c'est efficace mais pas à 100%
c'est ça va aussi du 40 à 60%
est un peu plus nombre de doses
l'important c'est que lorsqu'on a une
réinfection ce n'est pas une réinfection
avec le virus qu'on vient d'avoir c'est
une réinfection avec l'autre virus avant
parce qu'ils sont différents les
variantes c'est vraiment différent donc
il y a des gens qui sont réinfectés par
le BA2 alors qui ont été infectés par le
micro ça ça arrive mais d'être infecté
par le même virus ça c'est vraiment rare
alors c'est pas une question
d'efficacité vaccinale c'est une
question essentiellement de virus qui
sont différents ce qu'on normalement là
ce qu'on voit c'est que c'est possible
d'être réinfecté on le voyait moins
avant avec le micro on en a vu beaucoup
de réinfections il y a des gens qui
avaient fait des infections de d'autres
variants avant qui l'ont fait avec le
BA2 on a à peu près 5 à 10% des cas qui
sont des cas de réinfection ils ont fait
un BA2 il y a quelques semaines quelques
mois et là maintenant un homme micron
pardon et là maintenant il faut un bad
alors il faut anticiper que ça ça peut
arriver et c'est un motif supplémentaire
pour dire que
lorsqu'on fait une infection on est
protégé bien sûr mais c'est très bien
d'avoir une vaccination solide pour se
protéger des risques graves de cette
maladie on est à 4 on est parmi les
endroits les plus vaccinés
91% voir le tableau première dose au
Québec
87% la deuxième dose et 54 là sa
plafonne un peu la troisième dose Dr
Boileau quand vous regardez dans votre
viseur ce qui se fait ailleurs en Europe
ce qui arrive ailleurs qu'est-ce que
vous voyez pour l'automne parce que
l'été on le sait ça va aller mieux on
est dehors l'automne est-ce qu'on doit
s'attendre à une résurgence de quelque
chose qui va vous forcer imposer des
mesures
je pense qu'il faut s'attendre à ce que
le virus dans une forme actuelle ou une
nouvelle forme un nouveau variant ou des
variantes qui apparaissent déjà là on en
a déjà va certainement réapparaître dans
la collectivité et va faire son son
chemin de pour survivre et pour
contagieux pour contaminer le plus de
monde possible et il faut anticiper
qu'il y aura une invitation à aller
chercher un bon booster une bonne dose
de rappel pour se protéger contre ce
nouveau ou scène ou quatrième parce que
un peu comme l'influenza on a des cycles
comme ça où on invite les gens à
profiter d'une vaccination et que les
gens ont déjà commencé à apprendre
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire être
contaminé qu'est-ce que ça veut dire se
protéger et on va les inviter à le faire
et on anticipe pas et on ne souhaite pas
avoir des mesures populationnelles
lourdes comme le fermer des choses
empêcher des gens de faire ci faire ça
c'est pas le souhait il faut quand même
rester on ne sait pas ce qui peut
arriver mais c'est pas le souhait avec
les éléments que l'on dispose
aujourd'hui on ne croit pas que ça
devrait arriver mais comme vous dites on
a déjà été déjoué merci beaucoup docteur
Boileau très éclairant